[Music]
we are in the western side of that
Lambayeque Valley in the north coast of
Peru this is an area where in the past
many many important pre-columbian
societies develop party really the mochi
and the Lamba icky this is an area that
is super interesting from many point of
views no ecology the creation of
landscape the creation of culture and in
the center of everything is these
complex of pyramids called - tuna torn
and cup are we in a hurry
yes damaged by water
Ludi an encroachment is the biggest
threat to archaeological sites all
around the world that's why we are here
in to tuna looking at an excavation
helping people like Carlos Western do
his work the Sutan was maintained for
Venice was perdido Barrios monumentous
kita can see you are resolved for
healing Clemente or causal del rio's
como consecuencia de lluvia
is to soon working with kappa i say
peligro - sinister presencia key no
solamente very sad escalation ecológico
sahabas car formas devi turista
destruction
yes tofurna pasen por el ouzo there a
technology I use at all of main
suficiente para prevenir flow disasters
psychologists have always been looking
for better ways of doing their work
we're very poor to distich we are in the
early stages of using drones for this
type of work finally we can fly above
our excavations and take a picture that
reveals everything that we have been
seen from below within a day we can have
other pictures taken and we can have
three-dimensional models and by the next
day I will have a completely developed
assessment of what to do to prevent
damage produced by water so what one
drone can do in one hour is the
equivalent of what we could do it with
traditional methods in three months
drones only fly they take pictures we
don't have a real confirmation of what
is below the ground and for that we need
archeology archaeologists a destructive
process when we dig we destroyed so we
have to be extremely careful to record
everything we find in the ground
[Music]
Cueto CONOPS Abruzzo my ass go okay take
a siesta man Maria's para su
conservacion una las Primera's
condiciones hacer todo lo posible para
recuperar our enemy horas condiciones
los bienes ESO pasa no solamente poor
general conditions conservation O'Day
registrar owes the hacer photography
video the ojos scar Yoko's antennas
$8.00 materiales we are rushing to save
sites before they are destroyed and the
truth of the matter is that they are
destroyed on a faster pace that we can
rescue the information that they contain
there are many reasons for studying and
preserving the past we are only the
continuation of a process that started a
long time ago and many of the problems
that we have today and only resolved if
we look back at how we came to be in the
way we are
[Music]
[Music]